hey Brian this is a George colony on the
CEO Forrester Research when you ask the
question of what he's been motivated and
as a CEO of a company what really gets
me excited this will sound living like
BS but it's how i feel is seeing people
come into Forrester do great work get
promoted to even greater work and to
achieve their fullest potential watching
the people forced or move ahead some
young would be actually quite young and
the netter do fantastic things for our
clients move ahead learn learn new
skills do great things and to see them
develop that's really what keeps me
motivated so it's a knee in the 70s that
covers the human potential boobs to see
people reach the highest potential
that's the cool thing about baking
business for me hope that helps